I think Layla and I have a very
different love than most people who are
married and together but I would say
that it is absolutely founded in respect
I just respected her and she respects me
until that point I probably had the more
traditional relationships that were just
like more lovey-dovey more chemically
more robots Etc but the thing is like
I'm a really extreme person the biggest
thing that made me really love Layla was
just that she has never tried to change
me it was pure acceptance on this is
Alex like I'm not gonna get him to dress
a certain way I'm not going to get him
to behave a certain way nothing she just
was like you do you and I will do me
next to you and as long as we've grown
where we're going we'll get there and
have a good time